President Bush everyone knows fell last
month people are wondering how he's
doing you guys are good friends how is
the president doing stewing well he he's
got a neck brace on its back in Maine
he's healing and because he's got a
brace on he's cranky and crotchety but
other than that he's fine he's
absolutely incredible he's he's you're
I'm always hearing he's leaping out of
airplanes I gave a commencement at
Dartmouth a few years ago and he was so
charming so lively so full of fun he was
there at the event and it was fantastic
he was like year ago you know you will
think of him as a man that old a year
ago was his 90th birthday I was up there
he parachuted out of a plane out of the
helicopter and and he's claiming he's
gonna do it again when he's 95 that's
incredible that's amazing and wrong
Barbara keep Stan don't do that
in the book you say that for every
decision the president makes he makes
one enemy and one friend and that you
felt at least one enemy and one friend
and and my job was to make sure that the
people that wanted to be angry at the
decision were angry at me and those that
were happy about the decision were happy
for him I could use a guy like you it's
not that hard a job yeah all right tell
us because you know we're in the process
right now of trying to decide who our
next president should be it feels like
we constantly are in this country that
we rarely have much of a chance to
consider the presidencies that have that
have come before us George HW Bush what
made his presidency so special in your
opinion well you know most people
remember him as just having served one
term and maybe having been a great
president on foreign policy but but he
really was an amazing president on
domestic policy as well he proposed and
passed more legislation than any
president except Lyndon Johnson and
Franklin Roosevelt and he did all that
in one term and he was the right guy at
the right time when the Soviet Union
began to feel like it ought to be
talking to the west and
working out our differences and he was a
master of personal diplomacy got our
allies in the right way
got Gorbachev to feel comfortable and
really nurtured the collapse of the
Soviet Union and and we're all still
even though things are getting a little
tough lately he's still benefiting from
from that change that occurred wasn't
that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]